[Musik]
wir rücken
hallo herzlich willkommen so sehr liebt
es heute gibt 314 einem ich habe vor
kurzem eine reflexion buttermilch waffen
vorgestellt das war ein grundrezept um
dieses könne jederzeit zu bereiten und
heute eigentlich drei ideen darauf
vauban können zum einen habe ich zum
schmecken machen dann gibt's regenbogen
waffen und braune wasser alle drei sind
wirklich unglaublich lecker und fliege
staaten hier zuerst mit dem fisch
schmecken wochen losgeht mit den fünf
schnecken woche darf ich mein basic
bereits vorbereitet und freut euch mal
die übrigen zutaten für die fünf
schnecken waffe 100 hamburger 75 kam
paul und luca eineinhalb teelöffel sind
und für france den zwei esslöffel
frischkäse vier esslöffel zucker eine
zitrone und etwas von elektra jetzt
bereite ich erst ruhe darf in den gips
wie butter die kommentieren einen
kleinen topf und da erwischt es schmilzt
aber sie müssen natürlich kommen
allerdings nur leicht warm werden
jetzt kommt ihr der braunen zucker mit
rein und auch das films pulver und das
für ruhiges kurz und dann habe ich meine
zukunft wert
[Musik]
gibt es kurz abkühlen lassen und fühle
sich jetzt in einen spritzbeutel ohne
schüler ihr könnt auch zum beispiel
einen gefrierbeutel nehmen es ganz egal
ich hab jetzt in den abgelaufenen bei
mir wieder besser werde
[Musik]
allerdings trifft freunde schließlich
jetzt und kann es sind sie privat schon
aufwarten dafür das waffeleisen aber das
kennt ihr auch schon zu meinem besic
video
da kommt jetzt der waffelteig nein und
damit strecken waffeln werden schneiden
für eine kleine spitze direkt und
verteilt sind wodurch schneckenförmig
auf dem teig
[Musik]
die waffe im aufgebacken und musik ganz
schön an der oberfläche dass das zu
karibischen karamellisiert ist weiß ich
aber dass mit der rolle waren wollt
könnt ihr natürlich gebot masse auch
einfach in den tag hinein geben habt
aber dann nicht die schöne
karamellisierte super oberfläche retten
jetzt hier noch mit dem abkühlen lassen
und kann schon mal ein loch gegen
vorbereiten das heißt ich berührt
einfach die zutaten frisch käse und
butter zucker zitronensaft und von dem
extrakt
[Musik]
das typische vanillecreme crafting was
man gerne was sind stellen gibt und
damit kann ich jetzt die wochen gleich
verwerten
[Musik]
regenbogen mache und war ich jetzt dafür
den basics zubereitet und ihn bereits
auf wechsel sind aufgeteilt in denen ein
puzzle fehlen wie ihr eben auch farben
habt ich nehme die farben gelb orange
pink lila grün und blau und dafür
nämlich leben für die verpasste und geht
da einfach so viel mit dazu das ist das
schöne kräftige farbe bekommen
[Musik]
und der zeigt wird es jeweils in einen
spritzbeutel eingeführt weil sie keinen
spritzer habt könnt ihr auch wie gesagt
einen gefrierbeutel piloten
[Musik]
die beute habe jetzt schon verschlossen
und vorne eine kleine spitze
abgeschnitten
jetzt hätte ich das waffeleisen jetzt
könnt ihr die spritzbeutel nacheinander
in die hand nehmen und darauf spritzen
ist natürlich schnell machen wenn das
heim geht ja auch schnell auf ihr könnt
mit einem regenbogen spritzen oder
einfach kleckse draufmachen ganz sehen
möchte
[Musik]
das dritte wasser rezept sind braune
waffeln dafür gibt's auch wieder den
basic teig und habe ich die 100 gramm
schokolade geschmolzene schokolade mit
über 60 prozent kakaoanteil
und weil hier noch 100 gramm backwerk
verschob sein rühren
[Musik]
jetzt können auch die braun die waffen
ausgebacken werden
[Musik]
ein
ich finde wenn alle fertig backen machen
habe ich mit dem triumph crafting
serviert die regenbogen waffeln mit ein
bisschen gestreut dekor im bund und
schweiß geschlagener sahne und die
waffeln mit einer kugel vanilleeis pass
technisch sehr guter meter
schokoladensauce und jetzt könnt ihr
euch im prinzip für einen der drei
entscheiden oder auch alle drei zu
bereiten die rezepte findet die
einzelnen auffälliges - blog.de und ich
wünsche euch jetzt mal ganz viel spaß
beim nachmachen und ja richtig schöne
waffe woche also bis dann
[Musik]
du weißt